[Music]
dedicated fans crammed into a
sixth-floor screening area straining to
get a glimpse of Outlanders stars
katrina valve and Sam heughan at the New
York premiere you are here I don't know
who are you
why are you here let's find you maybe
because this show combines romance
time-travel action and more romance take
a few years really do those steamy
scenes get any less awkward to film
there they are always a challenge no I
think you know they're very integral to
the story and to their relationship yeah
I mean they're never easy to shoot yeah
I mean it's not as awkward as the first
time for sure I think it's really
important that we represent that and you
make it feel as honest and real as
possible honest and real translates to a
lot of shirtless time for Sam when we
visited the set season three finds Jamie
and Claire separated for 20 years so
there will be some sparks when these two
reunite the Fenton I want to come back
think that people are invested because
they believe in this love that Jamie and
Claire have and so you're definitely
going to see that
[Music]
Oh